[تصفيق]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
وبركاته دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
غيرت مجرى التاريخ فبلادنا بالرغم من صغر
سنها قدرت في خلال 45 سنه انها تكون بلاد
رايده في مجالات متنوعه فعلى سبيل
المثال ابوظبي اماره رايده في مجالات
كثيره منها الفن والمبادرات البيئيه وما
ننسى دورها في ترسيخ بصمه الامارات في
السياسه العالميه واليوم دبي من اكثر
الوجهات المحبوبه للسياح في العالم
والشارقه قدرت تستقطب عدد من المثقفين من
حول العالم وله السبب نسميها بعاصمه
الثقافه
فانتوا هاي المسيره بدات سنه
1971 يوم الشيخ زايد والشيخ راشد واخوانهم
حكام الامارات توحدوا واسسوا هاهاي الدوله
واليوم احنا نكمل هاي المسيره ونحمل
الرايه اللي بطموح ن نقدر نوصل بلادنا
للمركز الاول في سباق الدبي انتم مثل ما
تعرفون من حوالي 200 سنه كان شي ثوره
صناعيه في الغرب وبعدها ب 100 سنه قام
العالم يلاحظ مدا تاثيرها على كل نواحي
الحياه فغيرت نوعيه تفكير الناس والمجتمع
وغيرت منظور التجاره والصناعه والابتكار
ففي هك اليوم اشتعلت شعله شعله العلم
وشعله الابتكار اللي لين يومكم هاي حيه كل
ما يطوف عليها يوم تزيد
وتكبر وبسب هالشيء ودت هاي الدول الغربيه
لقمه اعلى وهني تطبق حكم القوي على
الضعيف وما في شي يمنعنا من ان احنا نقوم
بهذا التحويل يودينا من المرحله اللي احنا
فيها الى المرحله الاخرى بس عشان نقوم
بهذا التحويل لازم يبدا التحول من احنا
والله سبحانه وتعالى يقول في القران
الكريم لا يغير الله ما بقوم حتى يغيروا
ما بانفسهم صدق الله
العظيم ف في ثلاث مكونات نحتاجها عشان
نقوم بهذا
التحويل الاولى هي الرؤيه وما في مثال
اقدر اعطيكم اياه احسن عن صاحب السمو
الشيخ محمد بن راشد ال مكتوم يا مطلخ
الشيخ محمد المبادره ان الامارات طرش
مسبار الى المريق بسنه 2021 حط هدف كبير
وصعب وحتى لو ما وصلنا وان شاء الله بنوصل
هالهدف روحها سو انجازات
كبيره اسسوا مركز محمد براشد للفضاء علموه
شبابنا في علم الفضاء اخترعوا وصنعوا
مجسمات ما كانوا يسوونها لولا هاي الرؤيه
وهاي ميزه الرؤيه خصوم تكون كبيره ومليئه
بالتحدي انا احثكم لا تخافون انكم تحلمون
لا تخافون يكون عندكم رؤيه كبيره ولا هدف
كبير لان حتى لو ما بتنجح بتتعلم
وتستفيدون وهعلم اللي بتحصلونه يساعدكم
انكم تحققون اهدافكم
الاخرى المكون الثاني هو العزيمه والاراده
فانتم مثل ما تعرفون من شبابنا كنا هني
معتمدين على مهنه الغوص والبحث عن اللولو
وكان الغواص عادي يتم في البحر حوالي 12
ساعه في
اليوم لمده اربع شهور وكان هاي كانت مهنته
والرزق اللي كان يحصله من هالشيء كان بس
يغطي ديونه اللي تراكمت عليه طول السنه
وهو يحاول يعيل هله وعياله فكانت لهم حاجه
غير طبيعيه اللي ولدت اراده غير طبيعيه
وفي مقوله وايد احبها تخص ه الموضوع تقول
اي شيء يستطيع عقل الانسان تخيله تستطيع
الاراده البشريه ان تحققه والحمدله احنا
اليوم عايشين في نعمه بس لازم نشتغل اكثر
لانه مو بشرط لو واحد عنده فكره حلوه
بينجح فلوس بستوي ملياردير لا ما بت
الدنيا
لعبه فلازم لو عندك فكره تشتغل عليها وتكد
ليل والنهار عشان تخلي ه الفكره تحولها
الى حقيقه لا بتم
فكره فقبل ما اقوللكم المكون الثالث
والاخير خلوني اذكركم باول مكونين الرؤيه
العزيمه المكون الثالث هو
العلم فالحمد لله احنا في دوله الامارات
اغلبيتنا متعلمين وسبحان الله اكثر
المتعلمين نسبتهم من البنات وه شيء جميل
لان لان الرجال يوم متعلمه بيشتغل وبيد
وبيبكي تعلمها تطلع لك جيل مبتكر الام
مدرسه ان اعددتها اعددتها شعبا طيبا
الاعراق
ف اليوم العلم نور وهذا النور اللي بنير
لنا طريقنا الى النجاح والحمد لله متوفر
الحين في كل مكان بس مو بالشرط بس نتعلم
في المدارس والجامعات لا لازم نتعلم حتى
من الكتب والمقالات والانترنت وحتى
الفيديوهات اللي على
الانترنت وقبل لو رتبنا الزمن كنا بنكون
عايشين في عالم و العلم ما يكون متوفى
بهسهوله كان العلم يصعب انك توصل وكانوا
يقولون اطلب بالعلم ولو في
الصين
واحين قمنا احنا نفتكر ونسوي اغلب
الابداعات عننا من خلال ج جهاز الحاسوب
فهذا الجهاز جهاز جميل لان اليوم مو بشرط
بس تتعلم اللغه الانجليزيه لا تتعلم لغه
البرمجه ولغه الحاسوب ليش عشان لو عندك
فكره تقدر تكتبها بهال اللغه تتحول الى
كود عقب هالكود يتحول الى برنامج او تطبيق
وعقب ال برنامج ولا التطبيق يكون ف ه
الجهاز مثلا فانت تخيل لو عندك فكره تخيل
الفرحه اللي بتيك انك تعرف ان هاي الفكره
استوت في جيب كل واحد اتمنى هاي فرحه مو
طبيعيه وبالمكونات هاهاي الثلاث بتقدروا
تسوونها ان شاء
الله احنا المستقبل والمسؤوليه اللي علينا
م
بحينه وشيوخنا الله يحفظهم حاطين كل املهم
فينا ومالنا وي نخي لهم فعلينا نرد نشعل
شعله العلم والابتكار والابداع مره ثانيه
اللي بدايتها تكون من دوله الامارات
وتنتشر حول كل الدول العربيه ونكون سبب في
رجوع المجد للعرب والدول العربيه فب
الرؤيه والعزيمه والعن نوصل للمركز الاول
في سباق الدول
[تصفيق]
شكرا
ه